bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors qu'on conduit par
emmanuel macron le 28 octobre dernier
tous les quinze jours le point sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie alors beaucoup
de questions qu'est ce qui va être
annoncé vraisemblablement ce ne sera pas
à l'assouplissement des règles n'ont
sans doute pas il était prévu de toute
façon que ce confinement se pousse
jusqu'au 1er décembre
l'idée dans la tête du gouvernement
c'est de tout faire pour endiguer la
nouvelle vague
le nouveau nombre de cas qui se déclare
pour que les fêtes de fin d'année
puissent se dérouler d'une manière ou
d'une autre un ça veut pas dire qu'elles
vont se dérouler de manière classique je
pense compte tenu de l'ampleur de
l'épidémie
donc on attend évidemment des annonces
des annonces qui viennent encore une
fois de ce fameux conseil de défense 1
où tout est décidé entre quatre murs
sous le sceau du secret défense avec des
gens des personnalités choisies par
emmanuel macron qui depuis le début de
cette crise décide seul de la façon dont
nous devons français s'adapter à cette
crise sanitaire
on l'a vu le déconfinement à être les un
fiasco total
on la france est un des pays les plus
touchés c'est aussi un des pays où on
fait de plus de tests c'est un pays où
il faut soigner il faut saluer la force
des soignants qui arrive avec les
nouveaux protocoles de ranimation avec
tous les efforts qu'ils mettent dans
leur travail à sauver des vies à éviter
que le nombre de morts ne n'éclate
compte tenu de l'ampleur des
contaminations alors j'allais en venir à
ce conseil de défense un sanitaire ont
tout semble se décider justement le
gouvernement est conseillé par qui
appuyée par qui lorsqu'il prend des
décisions bien c'est toute la question
c'est ce qu'on aimerait savoir
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs plaintes qui
ont été déposées des enquêtes qui vont
être en cours mais qui seront limités
par ce secret défense issue du conseil
de défense
on avait le conseil des scientifiques
autour d' emmanuel macron au début un
qui le conseille mais ça ne voulait pas
dire qu'il écoutait est là aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas qui est qui et au sein de
ce conseil de défense à géométrie
variable que ce soit des débuts des
professeurs émérites des politiques des
responsables
d'administration et c'est donc ça reste
extrêmement opaque
c'est volontaire parce qu'au final ça
permet bien de ne pas justifier ses
décisions autrement qu'en disant fait
des efforts c'est d'ailleurs ce que
demande jean castex que les français
fassent des efforts pour finalement pas
lié aux banques de gestion de ce
gouvernement depuis le mois de mars et à
cette rentrée de septembre qui n'a pas
du tout était planifié
comme si le virus avait disparu pendant
l'été alors c'est compliqué pour les
commerces compliqué pour ceux qui
travaillent complètement un ferme et ans
et commerce le confinement les met dans
une situation plus que délicate
est ce qu'on les a si bien sûr que non
on essaie de passer quand on entend
bruno le maire parlait de mesures ce
sont des mesurettes parler de 500 euros
pour aider les commerces de proximité à
se digitalise et ce sont ses mots c'est
à dire à essayer de concurrencer amazon
c'est ridicule on voit bien aussi que
les dispositifs de chômage partiel vont
être allongés donc ça veut dire que ces
mesures de confinement vont sans doute
était de répétition vous continuez on
avait le click and collect le stop and
go on aura le confinement et le
déconfinement et ça pendant des mois
parce que le vaccin si jamais il devait
arriver il n'arrivera pas avant le
premier trimestre 2010 21 compte tenu
des autorisations des autorités
sanitaires dans chaque pays
donc aujourd'hui les commerces sont
aidés mais peu parce que ce qui aide les
commerces c'est une économie qui va bien
une croissance des consommateurs une vie
en fait où on a confiance où on peut
aller se rendre à aller et venir comme
on l'entend et pouvoir consommer
correctement parce que aujourd'hui le
confinement fait que les premiers à en
souffrir sont les plus précaires
évidemment sont aussi ces commerçants
qui eux ont des z
mais ces aides ne vont pas éviter
certaines feuilles qui sont
malheureusement inévitable compte tenu
du manque d'activité et du peu de
visibilité que nous avons sur une
reprise d'activité à partir de 2021 donc
non aujourd'hui les aides elles ne font
que ralentir décaler les nombreuses
faillites malheureusement qui vont
arriver
alors ya un problème manifestement dans
le protocole sanitaire appliquée dans
les établissements
scolaire parce que la fermeture des
lycées par exemple ça peut être une des
options envisagées par le gouvernement
qui va être annoncé tout à l'heure
oui ça peut-être une option mais ça
voudrait dire un désaveu majeur pour
jean michel blanquer remise de
l'éducation nationale qui a tout fait
pour garder les établissements ouverts
pour la continuité pédagogique comme il
le dit malgré les alertes des
professeurs des parents d'élèves des
élèves eux mêmes
on a vu un les chiffres du ministre qui
parlait de 3500 élèves contaminés qui
sont faux évidemment il ya beaucoup plus
d'élèves qui ont été contaminés beaucoup
plus de professeurs qui ont aussi été
touchés par ce virus
et on a bien vu la rentrée s'est faite
comme si le virus n'existait pas et
c'est maintenant 3 mois plus tard
comprend les mesures qu'on aurait dû
prendre en septembre c'est à dire des
cours différés d'au mieux aussi des
cours à distance
quand on entend que six mille
ordinateurs vont être distribués mais
quelles sont ces ordinateurs pourquoi
seulement 6000 comment ça se passe la
question aussi des familles les plus
précaires qui n'ont pas forcément
d'accès à la dématérialisation à des
cours à distance comment faire pour que
cela il est également comment faire en
fait pour que les lycées les
établissements scolaires soient protégés
autant que faire se peut alors que ça
n'a pas été le cas le virus s'est
emballée aussi parce que la gestion du
ministère de l'éducation nationale a été
une catastrophe
sous les ordres de jean michel blanquer
donc si jamais le gouvernement venait à
appeler a fait une fermeture
je ne vois pas comment jean michel
blanquer pourrait encore une fois sauvé
la face alors qu'il est souvent désavoué
c'est vrai mais là ça commence à faire
beaucoup
avec en plus ce scandale sur un syndicat
lycéen qui auraient bénéficié de
largesses de la république en marche
pour des nuits d'hôtel et des voyages
sous l'égide de jean michel blanquer
alexis poulain merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
édito raidissement à perrin un discours
à 18h de jean castex aujourd'hui